[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVEN MULLER:
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Stephen.
I'm business development
manager at Google Play.
Along with my
colleague, Brian, we
hope to regale you
with some tools
and tips for growing and
engaging users on Google Play.
Google Play gives you access
to a massive [INAUDIBLE]
of one billion potential users.
Your challenge as a
developer is to [INAUDIBLE]
the right users, user
feedback to improve your app,
and engage them in the long run.
We're going to walk
you through some tools
that Google Play offers
to make this easy.
We've parted out some
of the topics here.
I'm going to cover store
listings and experiments,
Brian will then cover
interactions with users,
translation, alpha/beta testing,
as well as Developer Pages.
We have some cool
giveaways for you as well.
So, before I begin, I wanted to
share with you that, formerly,
I was a Naval officer
on a nuclear submarine
and actually see some
parallels between life
on a submarine and
a store listing,
that I'd like to share with you.
So, icons.
Icons.
They're everywhere.
My submarine, for example,
in itself, was an icon.
It represented strength
and deterrence.
You should be asking
yourself, what
does your icon say
about your app or game?
It's the first thing
people see and it
doesn't matter how great
your app or game is,
if no one downloads it.
An effective app icon,
app or game icon,
serves as a quick
identifier for your app.
And you should also think
about changing it up,
seasonally or perhaps
around holiday specials.
Next is your title.
It's also one of the
first things people see.
I can refer to my old submarine
as the USS West Virginia SSBN
736 Gold, Group
10, or I could just
refer to as the 736 Gold, which
is what most people called it.
Similarly, with
your app, you want
to keep it short and sweet.
Does anyone see the play on
words in this game's title?
You want to be thoughtful
about your brand
and anticipate the future.
For example, how a
version two look?
Next are descriptions.
You can imagine, on a submarine
descriptions are everywhere.
But the last thing you want to
do is go into a radiation zone
without wearing your
thermoluminescent dosimeter.
In your app, you want your
description to be short
and you want to use bullets to
highlight your product offering
and tell the user what your
app or game actually does.
This is also a great place
to talk about what's new.
On a submarine, you can
imagine, day in and day out you
get bored with the same
food, eating the same thing
100 days in a row.
But on occasion, we
would hear that there's
some new food coming and
we'd all get excited.
And I distinctly
remember one year,
sort of floating around at
400 feet below the surface,
we actually had turkey
on Thanksgiving,
believe it or not.
So that was cool.
We were excited
about what was new.
Similarly, with your
Play Store listing,
you could talk about a
potential UI redesign
or now that you may
be supporting where.
So this brings us to
store listing experiments.
This allows you to test
different parts of your store
listing page.
There are several
things you can test--
your icon, your featured
graphic, screenshots,
your promotional video,
and your description,
all to see how these assets may
improve your conversion rate.
On a submarine, we tested
various approaches.
Experiment A could have
been approaching a target
from beneath, whereas
experiment B could've
been approaching a
target from behind,
through the [INAUDIBLE].
We would then take
that data and decide,
what's the best way
to approach or targets
going forward, based
on their attributes?
Similarly, with store
listing experiments,
you can use data
instead of intuition
to optimize a text and
graphics of your store listing.
So you want to start
with testing icons.
Icons can have the
greatest impact,
either positive or
negative, on your installs.
Test early.
Second, you want to
have a question in mind
when you're testing.
You want to have an objective.
For example, does artwork
visualizing game play drive
more installs than
artwork that doesn't?
So, best practices.
Developers have been asking
us for best practices.
We would like to share with
you some things that we think
would help or that
you should consider
when running your experiments.
So first, as I mentioned
before, start with a hypothesis.
Then you want to test it.
You want to test one thing at
a time, you want to iterate,
and you want to do
the test long enough
to get statistical significance.
You don't want to cut
the test off too short.
And then, of course, you
want to pay attention
to the banner in the
Dev console, which
gives you your results.
Probably most importantly,
you want to be bold.
Minor little
adjustments probably
will be inconclusive, so
make big, broad changes
and test those.
I'm going to walk you
through a few examples
here from successful
game developers who
used store listing experiments.
For example, "Kongregate"
tested different icon art
and they saw a 91%
increase in installs
just by testing the icon.
As you can see, "Rovio"
used three rounds
of testing until they
found the optimal winner.
This may have taken
them a little bit longer
but it was completely worth
the investment as they're
able to iterate and
incorporate their learnings,
and they actually saw
a pretty good boost.
Does anyone see which
icon, which variant,
of which experiment
is the winner?
All right.
In contrast, here's
an experiment
conducted on screen shots.
"Dots," a game
developer-- they used
a very measured and
controlled approach when
testing their screen shots.
So they held everything
constant except the illustration
of the game play mechanics and
they also had a great result.
That's all for store
listings and experiments.
I'd like to thank you
and turn things over
to Lieutenant Brian.
Brian'll take the
helm and bubble you up
through the surface.
BRIAN QUIMBY: Thanks, Steven.
So now that you've
tested your store listing
page to see what resonates
best with your sailors,
your submarine is ship
shape and ready to launch.
So the next step is to
interact with your crew
through the ratings and review
section of the developer
console.
It's one of the most important
aspects of the Play Store
and it's incredibly easy for
you, the developer, to do.
So ratings are one at the top
ways that users will market
your app to other people.
They're are also going to help
you understand what users love
and hate about your app,
and how their sentiment
has changed over time.
Replying to reviews is
one of the best ways
to create meaningful
connections with your users
and show them that you
listen to their feedback
to improve your product.
Now, we listen to you
developers' feedback
and added some features
that you wanted most
within the developer console.
So the ratings
chart that you see
is now available on
the reviews page,
making it easy to track trends
and individual star ratings,
and you can also search
for specific reviews
and do a free text search
across all of your reviews.
Recently launched,
too, one of the most
requested features--
being able to get
a notification
once a user updates
a review you've responded to.
Now, ratings can materially
impact your installs.
So you want to work towards
improving your scores so
that you could even be
promoted by Google Play.
We have a minimum bar
of 4.0 for inclusion
in any of our merchandising
opportunities.
We encourage everyone
to get into a dialogue
with your users, replying to
both good and bad reviews.
It'll make sure there's not
a mutiny on your store page.
So here's an example from one
of my developers, "ZomboDroid."
If you ever need an
awesome app to make memes,
I suggest you check them out.
But you can see how
they're actively
responding to low reviews and
asking the user to email them
at their support address.
This serves a few purposes.
First, it's going to
help increase engagement.
Second, it looks much better
to users who've not yet
downloaded the app, to
show that the developer is
willing and able to respond
to technical questions
and support them.
And again, after you've worked
with the user on their issue,
going back and asking them
to update their review
can result in an increase in
your ratings and higher stars.
So, as the song
goes, in the Navy,
you can sail the seven seas.
Well, if we're doing
all of that traveling,
we also need to
make sure that we're
going to be speaking the right
language for the country whose
port that we're in.
Let's continue our
focus on the user
with a little different
twist, making sure
that they can effectively
interact with your Play Store
listing and app because
it's in their language.
So within the developer
console, you already have access
to a number of optimization
tips and recommendations,
and these now
include localization
and internationalization
options to help
you take your app global.
You can see these
recommendations bubbled up
within the to do section
under optimization tips.
Here you can see
the recommendations
to translate our store listing,
make the screenshots and videos
reflect our target APK
language, and translate
the actual strings
within our app.
So you can easily translate your
Play Store listing page either
by providing your
own translation text,
or purchasing professional
translations directly
from the Developer Console.
If you don't provide translation
text for your store listing,
Google Play will either show
an automated translation
or the default language
setting for your application
but neither of these is
ideal if your users have
a local language preference.
In addition to your
Play Store listing page,
you'll also want to
make sure that your
APK itself is translated
into other languages.
Fortunately, Google makes
this extremely easy as well.
Using the app
translation service,
you can easily purchase
professional translations
for your APK strings and
in app items as well.
To find this option in the
Google Play Developer Console,
you'll want to sign
in and select an app,
and then click on
APK on the left side.
At the bottom, by this APK
Translation Service option,
you can click Start
or Check Progress
to launch the Google
Play Translation Manager.
After you've
selected the language
that you want to translate
your app or the strings into,
you can browse a list
of third party vendors
who are pre-qualified by
Google to offer high quality
translations.
You can upload the
strings that you want,
select the destination
or target language,
and then choose your translation
vendor based on time and price.
You can see the estimates that
are given in the Google Play
Developer Console for each
of these third party options.
Once you've purchased
translations,
you'll receive an
email from your vendor
and can then interact
directly with them
to work on your translations.
Once you've added translations
to your apps text strings,
you can upload the translated
APK file to Google Play
and translated versions
will be available to users
whose language preference
matches the translation
languages that you've added.
If you stop by later, I actually
have $100 translation service
coupons that you can pick
up at the tables over here
after filling out either
our developer profile
or a review of this session.
So now you should have a pretty
solid Play Store listing.
We've talked about
best practices
for your icon, title,
description, and then
using store listing
experiments to optimize
each of those for your users.
And then we've even
localized our APK
to make sure that the
language being displayed
on the store listing,
and in the app itself,
is right for our users.
I want to back up a
second, though, and talk
about strategies that you can
use when actually developing
your app in the first place.
Google Play has a
great tool called Alpha
and Beta Testing that
can help you prototype,
iterate, test, and
launch your app.
Alpha and Beta testing
is configured directly
in the Developer Console.
You have the ability
to upload the APK
and distribute it before
releasing to the public.
Users always have to opt
in to this functionality
and can never leave reviews.
And of course,
Google loves data,
so you'll have access to
a wide range of statistics
and information about the
Alpha and Beta configurations
to help you troubleshoot
and fix issues.
There are two ways to share
your Alpha and Beta builds,
open or closed.
Closed Alpha or Beta testing
is invite only and managed
through Google Groups.
This means you'll need to add
email addresses to a group
and then your users
will have access
to download the Alpha
and Beta builds.
You can also have
an Open Beta which
includes a custom URL that
anyone can join and opt into.
The developer can set a
maximum number of testers
and the overall progression
might be a Closed Beta
Test to an Open
Beta Test and then
actually distributing that
custom URL, via social media,
to your biggest fans to
get them early access
and get them testing
out your new app.
A number of top developers
have seen great success
with Alpha and Beta Testing to
ensure that new releases are
bug free and successful.
So now that you know how
to launch a great app,
the last topic I wanted
to touch on today
is a new, easy way to
promote your brand on Google
Play called Developer Pages.
Think of this is the nose art
on the planes of our aircraft
carrier.
It's going to get you
attention and your users
are going to love it.
So right now, if you click on
the developer's name in Google
Play, you're taken to a
rather bland page that lists
all of the developers apps.
Now, you actually
have the ability
to transform that space into
a unique page on Google Play
to promote your
entire app catalog.
With these Developer
Pages, you're
able to upload graphics, explain
what your company is all about,
and pick a special app
to feature at the top.
This gives you a
single destination
to promote all of your
apps on Google Play
and many of our top
partners have already
created their Developer Pages.
Check out Any.do they
have a graphic banner
at the top, a description of
the company and the options
that they offer, and then
a featured app at the top
of the screen as well.
And we know that you guys are
building for mobile, tablet,
wear, and TV, but Developer
Pages look great on desktop,
too, so you can link to them
from your app's website.
It's your own personal
branded page on Google.
This is one of my
developers, "Zidio."
They have an awesome graphic
at the top, some eye catching
description, and again, that
featured app on their Developer
Page as well.
Has anyone here created
a Developer Page yet?
Two?
Three?
Four?
You guys, right?
Not yet.
Soon.
So Steve and I have done
a lot of talking so far
and I was hoping to do
something interactive here
where we could actually build
a Developer Page together.
I don't know if you guys
have your laptops with you,
is that something maybe
we'd be interested in?
Maybe not?
Thinking about it?
All right.
I'll run through the steps.
If you guys want to follow
along with me real quick,
we can do that, too.
It's so easy.
It'll take a couple minutes
if you have some graphics
and tools ready for you.
So at the top of
the screen, we're
just going to sign into the
Google Play Developer Console
and click on Developer
Pages on the left.
And then we want to enter
some the information
that we're going to have about
our Google Play Store listing.
So promotional
text, 140 characters
to describe the brand, not
to be confused with a Tweet.
You can even add
translations of that as well.
Website, this should point
to your company website
or a website that's associated
with one at the top apps, maybe
the app that you're
going to feature.
Throw in some graphic assets,
so a developer icon that's
going to be in the circle
at the top of the page,
and a header image.
This header image
is going to be used,
not just on desktop, or that
big screen space at the top,
but also on mobile.
The recommended
apps section, it's
going to have the
graphic taking up
the full space
across the screen.
And then the featured app.
So Play will auto populate
all the different apps
you have in that
developer account
and you can select
one to pin at the top.
So if you're having a special,
if you have a seasonal item,
or something that you just
want to promote a little more,
you can click that
featured app right there
to sort of pin it to the top.
I'll give you guys a
couple minutes if you're
clicking through any of them.
I was hoping to even show
off one or two awesome ones
but I'm thinking you
guys are still working,
so maybe we can sort of
huddle over there later
and we can look at some
guys' Developer Pages.
I want to thank everyone
for coming to the session.
A couple quick items
that we can wrap up
with because I know Stephen
and I have been talking a lot
but we do want to talk with
all you guys individually, too.
And I think with
a group this size
we can probably head over
to the tables in the back
and maybe chat with
you guys one on one
if you have any specific
questions or issues with Google
Play.
Couple things I'd love for
you to do to help me out.
So at the top right
there is a quick survey
to tell me about this session.
Did you like the topics we
covered-- store listing,
Beta testing, Developer Pages?
Did you find it helpful?
And then number two,
and I love this one
because I got a custom
URL that big Android
barbecue at the end, but
I want you to fill out
a developer profile.
This is going to go
directly to Stephen and I,
and if you have any questions,
issues, need some help
with Google Play, strategies, or
tips, let me know in that form
and we're going to be
able to respond to you.
We also have a
great book, "Secrets
to App Success on Google Play."
This is written by
Google, contains
lots of juicy information
about your Play Store listing.
And you fill out those
two forms for me,
I'd love to send you
off with one today.
So with that, I'm going
to wrap up but again,
it'd be great to talk to
everyone later over here.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]